[Musica]
no
berlino guarda o qualcosa per te ciao
berlino
ciao ciao berlino come stai
no non si mangia è se il tuo nuovo amico
berlino no no non si mangia berlino non
si mangia e che cos'è quella berlino lo
vedi anche tu quella stampa vita e ma
che sta facendo
sì tutto bene tanto la passione un po di
pressing poli esercizi ok ti lascio fare
gli esercizi allora donano poco è ok
ciao
[Musica]
che cosa stava succedendo deve essere
stato il morso del lupo per fortuna è
solo un piede due zampe sicuramente è
stato il lupo che mi ha morso
forse mi sto trasformando in un lupo
mannaro o in un lupo lo sapevo aveva
ragione vitale non avrei mai dovuto
aprire quella scatola non avrei mai
dovuto prendere quel telefono non avrei
mai dovuto rispondere al telefono perché
non l'ho ascoltato ho un'idea per
nascondere queste zampe a che cosa sono
quelle che sono le mie bellissime le
ciabattine unicorno perché che c'è di
male
ok però posso chiederti se venivi a
mangiare un gelato fuori in giardino che
ne pensi la bella idea
ci godiamo questa bella giornata di sole
ok ti raggiungo tra poco inizia ad
andare ok ok io intanto vado a dopo ok a
dopo ciao sai qualcosa non essere
scoperta arriva aiutami tu che cosa
posso fare per interrompere la
trasformazione
dammi un consiglio ok grazie
proverò a fare finta di niente e allora
[Musica]
vogliamo realizzare non si accorga di
niente
e perché perno così qualcosa di strano
in bocca o no no no no no non mi dire
che quello che penso
no
[Musica]
senso
1 iniziale si sta insospettendo è meglio
che esco subito e lo raggiungo così non
sospettare di niente o no le scarpe non
vi entrano con questa specie che cosa
possono perderlo
ok ho trovato una soluzione per i piedi
speriamo che di tale museo conca di
niente eccomi
ciao mib a vivere su un cerotto anche
per me
no non venivi più e quindi ho detto ok
io comincio a mangiare il mio gelato
proprio questo caldo magari si scioglie
se lo prendevo pure per te tu sei sempre
lenta e sempre il solito potevi prendere
un gelato anche per me
ma cosa sia successo ai denti anche
perché parli anche in modo strano si
perdoni il mondo giornalistico
no non parli in modo normale non visto
pure qualcosa farvi vedere in atti che
strano perché non mi dai un pezzo litio
nato in belgio lato il mio nonno e mio
nonno
vatti a prendere il tuo gelato musical
news la do dammi un pezzo dichiarato
vitale stai bene io non volevo non
volevo spaventarti non so che cosa sia
successo ma quelli cosa sono niente sono
cresciuti adesso cosa è successo lì
che cosa ti è successo ai piedi anche
questi sono cresciuti adesso piedi
pelosi
ma dove sono il mio gelato solo tu
calmati comodi vitale e il gelato un lay
mangiato più o meno poi insomma si
svenuta in giardino
cosa svenuto in giardino perché e beh è
una lunga storia primo per i miei denti
da lupo mannaro e poi per i miei piedi
pelosi spero ci sia una spiegazione a
tutto questo
sì c'è una spiegazione ora ti racconto
tutto e mi dispiace in una parte lo ha
detto prima ma spero che tutto si
risolverà solo senza che ti dovresti
dire niente ma le cose stanno
peggiorando
anzi penso che la trasformazione stia
progredendo e se non facciamo qualcosa
subito mi trasformerò completamente in
un lupo mannaro trasformazione lupo
mannaro
ma cosa stai dicendo i ricordi che mi
avevi detto di non aprire mai più la
scatola e non prendere mai più niente
della scatola sì certo che me lo ricordo
beh c'era un telefono che squillava
insomma è una lunga storia poi mi hanno
risposto e poi era un'altra prova e io
ho risposto anche se non avrei dovuto
rispondere poi sono qualità che non si
sapra mangerò un lupo
e venuto qua in camera e poi lui mi ha
morso e penso che sia il lupo che mi ha
morso che mi ha iniziato attraversa
ormai il lupo mannaro il lupo il piano
di sopra che un punto informazioni non
sto capendo più niente
come possiamo fare ad interrompere
questa trasformazione adesso ha un idea
io penso che la trasformazione si
completerà non appena arriverà la luna
piena
quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci a trovare una
soluzione prima che arrivi la luna piena
quindi abbiamo pochissime ore in realtà
e se invece arriverà la luna piena
forse rimarrò per sempre un no la
trasformazione sta continuando dobbiamo
sbrigarci alla luna piena mi trasformerò
per sempre in un po andare
spieghiamo ci troviamo una soluzione mi
metto subito cercherà una soluzione va
bene mi raccomando però non metterti a
mangiare ok in uno come vederlo questa
sera mi metto a mangiare così dire no no
no va bene anche io cercherò una
soluzione fa prima che sia troppo tardi
ok ok vedo che cosa posso trovare
riuscirà a evitare la troveremo
assoluzione e poi lasciate un mi piace
per aiutarmi a trovare una soluzione mi
raccomando cliccate a me piace qua sotto
abbiamo pochissime ore di tempo
[Musica]